trailer Matt wall show Canada continues
to exterminate itself with its assisted
suicide epidemic it's gotten so bad that
retail brands are now using suicide to
sell their products also backlash
against balenciaga's child exploitation
continues to build though the criticism
from some Corners has been rather well
muted plus Apple goes to war with Elon
Musk and Biden's cross-dressing
bestiality fetishist energy official has
been charged with a felony after
stealing a woman's suitcase from the
airport and it only gets weirder from
there somehow all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
well the lack of a red wave during the
midterms lead to more Reckless spending
by a more emboldened by an
Administration higher taxes deeper
inflation if you're unsure how the next
two years will unfold talk to Birch gold
group about protecting your savings with
gold Birch gold makes it easy to convert
your IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals so you can own gold and silver in
a tax sheltered account here's what you
need to do text Walsh to 98 9898 to
claim your free info kit on gold then
talk to one of their precious metal
Specialists they will help you go
through the entire process and with an A
plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers in
almost 20 years of experience converting
IRAs and 401ks into precious metal IRAs
Birch gold can help protect your savings
also all you got to do if you want to
take advantage of that is text Walsh to
98 9898 and protect yourself with gold
today that's Walsh to 989898
if you live here in the United States
you need only look over our northern
border to witness one of the most
consequential and most dire events
happening in the modern Western World
and we've been following it on this show
and uh but you know outside of the daily
wire and a few other conservative
Outlets it has not gotten nearly as much
attention as it deserves
and I think that's partly because we're
all kind of overwhelmed with this
constant influx of information and it's
difficult to know which things we should
focus on and even if we know what we
should focus on it's hard to focus at
all on anything it's partly because the
event that I'm referring to is so dark
and depressing that most people prefer
not to talk about it or think about it
or acknowledge that it's happening and
yet it is and I'm referring of course to
Canada's suicide epidemic
what makes this suicide epidemic even
more alarming than the already quite
alarming suicide epidemic that uh is
happening in this country United States
is that in Canada
the epidemic is being funded and
facilitated and encouraged and glorified
by the Canadian government and the
medical establishment or as they prefer
to phrase it uh the suicide epidemic is
being assisted it is being assisted
assisted suicide or medical assistance
in dying in Canada as we've covered on
this show is becoming more and more
common with each passing year as the
quote service is opened up to more and
more people
last year 2020 2021 10 000 people died
by assisted suicide in the country which
is needless to say a lot and that was a
significant jump over 30 in fact uh from
the year before that
and this year we'll see we can be
certain in an even bigger jump as
assisted suicide is increasingly
inflicted on people not just for
terminal illness anymore but even for
physically healthy people people with
conditions quote unquote such as
depression mental illness homelessness
now there's a push for assisted suicide
for minors
assisted suicide also for patients who
have quote lost the capacity to consent
according to one of the Amendments
that's being proposed
they're trying to basically Shuffle as
many people as possible towards the exit
exits and it's working euthanasia is
rapidly becoming a leading cause of
death in many Canadian provinces
in fact Canada's euthanasia laws are so
relaxed and so devoid of safeguards or
limitations that they make the horrific
assisted suicide policies in places like
Belgium and the Netherlands look
downright responsible by comparison for
instance
Canada is the only country in the world
where assisted suicide can be carried
out by medical professionals who aren't
even doctors nurse practitioners can
kill people in Canada
not that it's any better if a doctor
does it of course but this just shows
how they're relaxing all the policies
not only that but Canada takes specific
steps to obscure and cover up the extent
of the euthanasia regime as the AP
reports quote medical authorities in its
two largest provinces Ontario and Quebec
explicitly instruct doctors not to
indicate on death certificates if people
died from euthanasia
not only that but even in Belgium
doctors are at least in theory
instructed not to recommend euthanasia
to patients as a potential treatment
okay the patient has to bring it up
himself at which point they'll happily
kill him now I'm extremely skeptical
that such a policy is actually followed
but in Canada they don't even bother
with that sort of policy in theory again
from the AP quote there are no such
restrictions in Canada the association
of Canadian Health Care Professionals
who provide euthanasia tell Physicians
and nurses to inform patients if they
might qualify to be killed as one of
their possible clinical care options
now
this uh helps explain the the story from
several months ago about the veteran who
called the VA looking for help with his
PTSD and instead he was told that he
should consider killing himself
so they're not just providing assisted
suicide to anyone who wants it for any
reason I mean they are doing that but
also they're actively encouraging it
they are advertising it they are
literally advertising it in fact the CBC
has this report quote quebec-based
retailer Simons made a deliberate move
toward inspiration last month as part of
a new video called all is beauty
the video is centered around and
narrated by BC's Jennifer hatch the 37
year old died on October 21st 23rd and
chose medical assistance in dying after
dealing with complications and chronic
pain associated with Her diagnosis of
ehlers download syndrome which is a
group of inherited disorders that affect
the connective tissue supporting many
body parts in the video available on
Simon's shopping website viewers get a
glimpse into some of the moments of
hatches last month and hear her share
her thoughts on life death and her quest
to fill her final days with Beauty with
nature and with connection Peter Simons
Chief Merchant for the fashion chain
says the documentary project started
after meeting hatch through the maid
program and traveling to Vancouver to
talk about working on a unique film
quote we really felt after everything
we've been through in the last two years
and everyone's been through maybe it
would resonate more to do a project
that's less commercially oriented and
more focused on inspiration and values
that we hold dear said Simons
Simon says that he thinks customers will
appreciate the unconventional move
well you tell me how much you appreciate
this here's the ad
last breaths are sacred when I imagine
my final days I see bubbles
[Music]
I see music
even now as I seek help to end my life
there is still so much Beauty you just
have to be brave enough to see it
[Music]
foreign
dystopian is vastly overused these days
but if it ever applied to anything it
applies to that it is truly one of the
most dystopian things I've ever seen a
fashion retailer using suicide to sell
clothing
and this is the way it always goes right
you take an evil thing be it assisted
suicide or gender ideology or abortion
or something else
and then you medicalize it
and after it is medicalized the brands
get a hold of it and it is corporatized
each part of the system each member of
this grotesque Human Centipede has its
own way of profiting off of the evil uh
profiting off of the destructive thing
but it's perhaps most viscerally
disturbing once the brands get to work
in this case trying to make suicide into
something inspirational and fashionable
almost like it's a sort of an aesthetic
choice to commit suicide
here's more of the CEO Peter Simons
explaining this campaign listen
it was perhaps hard to reconnect with a
hope and an optimism and we wanted to do
something that really underlined human
connection and perhaps would help people
to
reconnect to each other and to this hope
and optimism that that is going to be
needed if we're going to build the sort
of communities and and and spaces where
we we want to live and that are
enjoyable to live in
one thing we know about evil is that it
doesn't create anything of its own it
has no creative power it can only
subvert what already exists it takes
what is good and turns it on its head it
desecrates the holy and the sacred this
is why Satanic rituals are always
modeled after Christian rituals they are
parodies mockeries rather than
inventions and here we see how this
Satanist Peter Simons has made a parody
and mockery out of Hope
for him hope and optimism means
self-destruction the hopeful and
optimistic person is the person who has
given up on the future given up on life
which is of course the exact diametric
opposite of Hope and optimism it is the
death of Hope
it is the death of everything it is
death itself
and although the absurdity of this
rebranding is I hope obvious to most of
us
the extremely troubling point is that it
is not obvious to everyone
and it's becoming obvious to fewer and
fewer people as time goes on
the assisted suicide machine exists in a
society where people are conditioned to
find the suicide pitch appealing
they are conditioned to be susceptible
to this sort of propaganda
and in fact
this machine could only exist in such a
society to begin with
now let's get to our five headlines
don't be distracted by parties and
presidents this holiday season instead
join Hallows most anticipated prayer
challenge of the Year pray 25 led by
cast members from The Chosen the largest
Christian streaming Series in history
prey 25 will guide you through
meditation and prayer for 25 days
leading up to Christmas pray 25 will
help you grow your understanding of
mankind and develop a disciplined prayer
habit during a season when discipline is
put to the test to put it mildly hello
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the U.S and the number one Catholic
app in the world hello helps me make
prayer a priority and with pray 25 it
can do the same for you find peace and
fortify your faith this Christmas with
hallow you can download the app for free
and join pray 25 challenge go to
hallow.com Matt Walsh and get three
months completely free that's hello.com
Matt Walsh to reclaim your piece during
this holiday season
one other thought about this speaking of
the conditioning that makes suicide so
appealing in our society uh whether it's
the doctor-assisted variety or the uh
traditional sort of suicide I I am I
think the number one factor
that makes people susceptible to it is
the popular idea the misconception the
myth in our culture that life is not
supposed to involve suffering that
suffering is not supposed to be a part
of the bargain it's not supposed to come
with the existence package this is what
people are conditioned to believe so
that when they experience suffering
which they inevitably will because
everybody does because it does come with
life but when they when they experience
it they think that it means that
something is wrong with them something
is defective right they start feeling
they start experiencing suffering and
they're not feeling good and they think
well something's horribly wrong here I'm
not supposed to feel this way and they
go looking for a mental illness
diagnosis
um and then maybe ultimately they decide
that the defect is incurable maybe
they're even told in Canada they'll be
they might be told this there's nothing
we could do for you here's the one
treatment option we have available it's
uh it's the permanent sort of treatment
which is the end of your suffering
existence
but what people used to intuitively
understand is that suffering is part of
life it is it is part of life this is
the stuff that human existence is made
out of
like it or not
um and you're not gonna like it but it's
just true you can't avoid it you can't
run from it without running from
existence
and that's why that's why the goal
should not be to avoid suffering or to
come up with some sort of total cure for
it right to treat suffering itself like
it's a disease because it's not there
are diseases that can cause more
suffering and where you can
um help you know alleviate someone's
suffering in in an immediate sense we
should obviously do that
but suffering itself is not a disease
and the ultimate goal should not be to
create an existence for someone where
they experience no suffering it should
be to help them find meaning in the
suffering
because human beings can endure almost
any amount of suffering if they're able
to find meaning in it this is a man's
search for meaning Victor Frankel right
this is this is the Insight you can
endure anything if you have meaning in
your life but the flip side of that coin
is that you can endure almost nothing if
you have no meaning in your life
if you have no meaning then then then
the slightest Breeze might knock you on
your ass
so the crucial thing here is to help
people find meaning which cannot be
accomplished
through pills and through medical
procedures
this is what I've this is why I'm always
hammering on this point I'm not saying
that there's no role at all for
psychiatric drugs I think that there's a
at best at extremely limited role in
some extreme cases
but in most cases
you know what the fundamental problem is
is is not that someone is experiencing
sorry because that they they don't have
meaning in their life
and you could try to to numb that
you could try to come up with a Band-Aid
measure to cover it up but it's still
there that lack of meaning
and the answer is whether
no matter how you slice it it's a it's a
spiritual answer that's how you find
meaning in your life
there's no other place to find it
all right
so let's begin with Balenciaga the daily
wire has the latest the fashion company
Balenciaga responded to its ongoing
Scandal involving a photo shoot that
featured young children holding BDSM
themed teddy bear bags by saying that it
could have done things differently the
company issued the statement Monday
afternoon after facing severe public
backlash when it was accused of
sexualizing young children the brand
which celebrities like Kim Kardashian
often wear displayed images on its
website last week as part of its Toy
Story's campaign the photos showed child
models posing with Brands the Brand's
teddy bear handbags with the Bears
dressed in BDSM themed gear from its
Paris Fashion Week 2023 collection the
company said that it strongly condemns
child abuse it was never our attempt to
include it in our narrative
and yet they did
um they went through the trouble of
Designing this whole photo shoot and
they took the photos and they edited it
all down and they they came up with the
the advertising campaign and they
published all this stuff but it was
never their intent they just tripped and
fell and uh next thing you know they had
an ad uh you know featuring BDSM and
children
that's what we're supposed to believe
the statement said the first campaign
the gift collection campaign featured
children with plush bear bags in what
some have labeled BDSM inspired outfits
oh some have labeled yeah like the sum
being people with eyes have labeled it
that way are plush bear bags in the gift
collection should not have been featured
with children this was a wrong choice by
Balenciaga combined with our failure in
assessing and validating images the
responsibility for this lives with us
alone the second separate campaign for
spring 2023 which was meant to replicate
a business office environment included a
photo with a page in the background from
a Supreme Court ruling United States
versus Williams 2008 which confirms as
illegal and not protected by freedom of
speech the promotion of child
pornography
um so
it's of course the BDSM teddy bear
wasn't the only thing they also had as
they acknowledged in their statement now
they also had photos separate photos
featuring documents discussing child
pornography
actual explicit references to child
pornography that they included in this
ad campaign
um and now we have more updates this is
from the post-millennial says last week
luxury fashion brand Balenciaga fell
into controversy as disturbing and uh
exploitative images emerge from their
website of children pose in alarming
ways with sexualized paraphernalia such
as bondage gear sparking looks at the
company's chief designer who is Lara
volkova who has posted images on
Instagram of Satan worship as well as
child torture mutilation and
sexualization
on Twitter many users have posted images
from volkova's Instagram which is now
private d-transitioner Ali London posted
a sampling and wrote These are shocking
posts from balenciaga's stylist Lara
volkova who has a sick obsession with
torture Satan and child mutilation these
picks are Beyond disturbing but there
are far worse on our Instagram
and
we don't even need to put up the images
it's just it's exactly as it's described
it's satanic uh images of torture child
mutilation all of that that this
designer has posted in the past on her
Instagram and now has taken it all down
and put it all to private
so this is pure Satanism and it's uh
when you see the the absolute filth and
degeneracy and wickedness that is being
mainstreamed and promoted at the highest
levels of society
along with being infuriated and you know
making you cry out to God for vengeance
against these sick child abusing freaks
along with that it can be I mean it's
it's incredibly demoralizing and
dispiriting and uh
psychologically and spiritually
exhausting
to live in a culture where the rot is so
deep
and the sickness does feel sometimes
terminal
which as a parent that's a that is a
terrifying despair inducing thought
because this you know my kids are just
like your kids are inheriting this
culture
which is why what I really want to do
sometimes is just like take my family
and move into the woods and be done with
all this move away from the filth and
from the sadistic Twisted Predators who
wish harm on my children and on your
children
just you know move away from it
live a simple life somewhere somewhere
far away from it but I can't because
that's not what uh I'm called to do it's
not what most of us are called to do
we're called to confront this and fight
against it
and as for Balenciaga the most revealing
thing has been the reaction or lack
thereof in certain corners for example
Kim Kardashian who's the brand
ambassador for these child porn Peddlers
issued a statement that I mean it falls
well short of denouncing the company and
certainly Falls well short of pledging
not to work with them anymore in fact
she's indicated the opposite that she
will continue to work with them so this
was her statement she says I've been
quiet for the past few days not because
I haven't been disgusted and outraged by
the Balenciaga campaigns but because I
want an opportunity to speak to their
team to understand for myself how this
could have happened as a mother of four
I've been shaken by the disturbing
images the safety of children must be
um held with the highest Regard in any
attempts to normalize child abuse of any
kind should have no place in our society
period I appreciate balenciaga's removal
of the campaigns and apology and
speaking with them she said I believe
that they understand the seriousness of
the issue and will take necessary
measures for this never to happen again
as for my future with Balenciaga I am
currently reevaluating my relationship
with the brand basing it off of their
willingness to accept accountability for
something that should have never
happened to begin with and the actions
I'm expected to see them take to protect
children ah she's re-evaluating she's
reevaluating whether or not she should
continue to work with child porn
Peddlers
that's something she needs to reevaluate
you know there are some things on in
life I mean I
generally speaking I believe in second
chances for people but there are some
things in life where there is no Second
Chance like there are some things you
can do
where there is no you don't get a second
shot at it
um and one of them is Distributing
um
abusive and exploitative images of
children not just Distributing them but
also trying to you know trying to profit
off of them
that's not a quote unquote mistake that
is a deliberate thing that they did
because they thought they could get away
with it
and the only reason that they didn't get
away with it is just because of people
on social media
mostly conservatives who seem to be
upset about this
if not for that
they would have gotten away with it
because they they counted on people like
Kim Kardashian
you know they knew that I mean the only
reason the only reason Kim Kardashian
saying anything about it is because
she's been forced to do so
over on The View meanwhile their biggest
concern with children being exploited
and abused for an ad campaign is not
that it's happening they're not
concerned for the children themselves
but really that uh but rather that it
will it will play into the hands of the
far right listen
what's going on I found this ad campaign
particularly distasteful in this moment
so there's this there's growing
anti-lgbtq sentiment right now and it
how it's Being Framed is as portraying
you know trans people as groomers this
is a terminal here on the far right
they're groomers this is where you get
the anti-drag queen stuff that we're
seeing so Balenciaga played right into
their hands by having kids in a
sexualized manner carrying something
that represents you know sex acts I
think it was a really bad misstep at a
moment where it's just kind of a
dangerous time to even give Credence to
those kind of insane takes yeah I mean
we can't even show the picture because
it's so distasteful but what's also very
distasteful is like Balenciaga lately I
mean their stuff is just ugly I mean the
bag that the little girl is holding is
ugly do you remember when Kim K was
dressed in Balenciaga for the kids
look at that oh she looks like a bat or
something
that I mean everything you need to know
about these people is right there in
that video so what are their concerns a
fashion brand exploiting children using
uh sexually exploited images of of
children what's their concern one of
course their first concern is that it
might be damaging to uh you know the the
alphabet club uh that's their first
concern is is well what about the LGBT
people
child sexually exploited in ad campaign
LGBT community most affected
that's what that's what we get from them
which by the way
why are you bringing LGBT into this no
one on the right did that
that's you doing that I didn't see
anyone on the right
who saw this Balenciaga campaign and
said oh it's the LGBT people have done
that the people behind this I don't know
I don't know what their sexual
orientation is
um I don't know I don't know how they uh
self-identify doesn't matter I don't
need to know any of those details
we need we need to have we know
everything we need to know about them
based on the ad they put out
so that's a connection that they're
making on The View
and that's their first concern and their
second concern is just that the uh the
The Outfits or the the clothing the
apparel that Balenciaga puts out is ugly
and here's what we have to understand is
that these these people they are not
very eager to condemn the sexualization
of children
because they have no problem with the
sexualization of children in fact to be
more specific
they don't think that children can be
sexualized because they believe that
children are already sexual from birth
this is what Alfred Kinsey believed and
taught and he's one of the Godfathers of
the sexual Revolution this is his
culture and we're all just living in it
that's why it's so important to
understand the origins of this stuff
and this is what they believe
so they just don't see it as a problem
all right daily wire has this report
Disney's latest agenda pushing project
is off to a brutal start at the box
office Strange World an animated film
featuring a gay teen romance opened
Wednesday with a poor 4.2 million
dollars in ticket sales and is projected
to bring in as little as 21 million
dollars over what should be
strong holiday weekend the film which
pushes sexual orientation and climate
agendas is on track to be Disney's
latest over woke nightmare uh in fact
from what I've read they're looking at
um
losing a hundred million dollars on this
on this film actually the wokeness in
this movie goes even beyond the gay love
story thing at the center of it uh so
here's some more details from the daily
wire report Strange World tells the
story of gay teen Ethan voiced by
jabuki young white
jibbuki is that the
I was pronounced who has the support of
his loving biracial parents Searcher and
Meridian the family rejects its fabled
Heritage as explorers to farm but ends
up pulled back into the family business
to hunt for Searchers father Jager who
went missing when he was a child the
search is aided by their disabled dog
and takes them to
um avalonia a strange world with a
fragile ecosystem Ethan struggles to get
past as shyness around his love interest
a boy named diazzo so you got it so
you've got the gay teen with the
biracial parents
um it's a it's a story that centers
around a climate change and even the
even the dog is disabled like they they
even had to find a way
to inject some weakness there as well so
yeah full representation all the boxes
checked everything is going for it as
far as wokeness goes right as far as
political correctness goes every single
box checked but what they forgot is that
you're telling a story and the story
itself has to be worthwhile it has to be
a good story and um
people just aren't interested in it and
so it's looking at losing 100 million
dollars
one of the one of the biggest bombs for
Disney ever in history and by the way
that so the people on the left very
embarrassed by this especially coming on
the heels of I've already forgotten the
name of it you know that's part of the
problem I think with the oh is it the
the gay uh
romantic comedy Bros so coming on the
heels of that and that comes out and
nobody goes to see it okay it's it earns
I think it was like seven dollars
at the box office opening weekend that's
not even a full ticket somehow just half
of a ticket was sold just half of a a
ticket stub somebody bought and that's
all that it did in the box office it's
opening weekend so that's a a major bomb
of catastrophe and then Disney tries
something very similar but targeting
kids this time
um and in terms of money loss it's an
even worse bomb
so this is very embarrassing for the
left and uh they're coming up with ways
to
excuse this and of course one of their
so that one of their go-to explanations
is that well this shows there's
homophobia homophobia the fact that
parents don't want to bring their
children
to go watch you know a story revolving
around a romance between two teenage
boys that's homophobia that's part of
their
explanation and the other one is that
Disney that that actually Disney
sabotaged the film by intentionally not
promoting it and that's why if any if
only everyone had been told about the
gay teen cartoon romance then the
theaters would have been filled
to the rafters with people just just
itching to bring their kids to be
exposed to this kind of content
but Disney sabotaged it and I can tell
you right now that is not the case and I
can tell you for two reasons one of them
is anecdotal which is that I definitely
saw advertisements for this I am not the
target market for um Disney films and so
many Disney films come out and I don't
even know about them
that they they can they're in theaters
and they leave theaters and I never even
hear about them probably most Disney
films at this point I don't even hear
about them this one I heard about and so
it's anecdotal but I can say that if I
hear about it then it's definitely being
promoted at least to the level of other
Disney films and probably a lot more
than that
because this film got not only marketing
but it also got the free marketing from
the media
um
making a big deal about it because it's
a gay teen romance for kids
shattering the glass ceiling
so we know that's not true but also this
is not how movie studios work okay they
don't spend tens of millions of dollars
making a film
to then sabotage it on purpose
they want to make money on the project
so that is not the explanation the
explanation is that so it's it's not
that it wasn't promoted it's not that
everyone is homophobic
it's it's two things
one by all accounts just just looks like
a bad movie
where the message is put before the
story as I talk about all the time and
now we're seeing sort of the in a
Bizarro World version of the mistake
that uh the Christian film industry has
made for so many years where now the
message is diametrically opposite but
the mistake is in making the message
you're putting the message before the
story
so that
You couldn't possibly enjoy watching it
unless you're fully bought into them
you're only there for the sermon in
other words it's not you're not there
for the story itself you got to put the
story first
um
that's part of the reason why I bombed
and then and then also as far as the
message
this is not a message that most parents
are interested in exposing their
children to
it's just as simple as that
and you can complain about it all you
want
one thing you notice that most of the
people complaining about it are not
parents
so most of the people insisting that we
as parents should be eager to expose our
kids to gay teen romance
so there's nothing wrong with that as a
parent what are you talking about most
people saying that aren't they don't
have kids
they have no idea what they're talking
about
and even if they do have kids well I
feel sorry for their own kids but that's
not going to affect what I do with mine
and the simple reality is that most
people even people who would identify
themselves as liberal they vote Democrat
I mean the box office receipts show it
even most of those people
when push comes to shove they actually
don't want to sit in the theater with
their seven-year-old kid to watch a
story about a teenage boy that falls in
love with another teenage boy
don't want to see it
nor should they want to
all right this is from
the daily wires as well it says Twitter
CEO Elon Musk signaled Monday that he
might be preparing to go to war with
Apple after the company has largely
stopped advertising on Twitter and has
reportedly threatened to boot the social
media platform from its App Store musk
specifically called out Apple CEO Tim
Cook in a series of tweets where he also
raised the issue of censorship
uh musk says Apple has mostly stopped
advertising on Twitter do they hate free
speech in America what's going on here
Apple has also threatened to withhold
Twitter from its App Store but won't
tell us why
so this is this is the latest is Apple
going to kick Twitter out of its App
Store
and they won't say why because they're
not gonna they're not gonna say the
reason out loud
because the reason it's pure politics is
purely ideological
they don't agree with Elon musk's
politics and so they're going to punish
him by removing one of the most popular
apps in the world
from the App Store
it is a very fascinating thing to watch
ken because the question here is can the
system
coalesce
and team up to take down the richest man
on earth so you've got the richest man
on earth versus the system and the one
thing about the system is that is that
the the the the the people and the
institutions within it
you know they hate Elon Musk on
ideological grounds but they also hit
him even more because they feel betrayed
you know he's supposed to be on their
side
he's a wealthy Elite
he is the wealthiest and so therefore in
many ways the most elite person
on the planet and and there's he's so
he's one of theirs as far as they're
concerned
he's supposed to be in there
um demonic fraternity
and he's not and he's turned against
them and they hate him for that
keep in mind too that Apple so when it
comes to the to the App Store and yeah
there are other ways of accessing
Twitter you can access Twitter on your
browser
um but when it comes to the App Store
Apple and Google control access to the
App Store
like 100 percent
they have 100 control over it so it's a
it's a monopoly or duopoly
and yet here you have the left of course
you know taking Apple's side and
supporting a corporate Monopoly
on the grounds that well Apple can do
whatever it wants it's the pre the
rights of a private business
coming to the defense of the richest
corporation on the planet
which is trying to exercise Monopoly
power
in one of the most egregious and blatant
ways that we've seen in decades
and the and the anti-corporate the you
know left the supposed supposedly the
Socialists right are uh
coming to its defense
so they'll they'll defend the private
business rights of Apple
this multi-gazillion dollar Mega Global
Corporation
but when it comes to like a
a baker
just some random Baker in Colorado
who doesn't want to bake a cake for a
gay wedding
in that case no you don't have private
business rights
because there's it's it would be uh
there would be apocalyptic consequences
to allowing a random Baker
in a small town in Colorado allowing him
to decide for himself who he is going to
provide cakes to that would have
apocalyptic earth-shattering
consequences
and yet allowing the richest most
powerful Corporation in the world to
exercise these kinds of Monopoly Powers
um for political reasons that has no
that's that's no big deal
by the way the White House says that
it's keeping an eye on uh Elon Musk and
Twitter keeping an eye on the situation
let's listen to that
question about Twitter
um you know there's the researcher at
Stanford who says
is a critical moment really in terms of
ensuring that Twitter does not become a
vector for misinformation I mean are you
concerned about
Elon Musk says there's more and more
subscribers coming online are you
concerned about that and what tools do
you have who is it at the White House
that is really keeping track of this so
like this is something that we're
certainly uh keeping an eye on and uh
look
um we you know we have always been very
clear
um and that when it comes to social
media platforms it is their
responsibility to make sure that when it
comes to misinformation when we when it
comes to the hate that we're seeing that
they they take action that they continue
to take action again we're all keeping a
close eye on this we're all uh
monitoring uh what's what's currently
occurring and we see you know we see it
with our own eyes of what you all are
reporting and just for for ourselves
what's happening on Twitter but again
social media companies have a
responsibility to prevent their
platforms from being used by any user to
incite violence especially violence
directed at individual communities as we
have been seeing and the present has
been very clear on calling that out
he'll continue to do that and we're
going to continue to monitor the
situation
man she is so bad at this she's so
incredibly bad at this she's so bad
maybe this is the maybe there is some
brilliant strategy behind having um
you know Gene pair Karen Jean pair in in
that role maybe the strategy is that
like she Rambles and has this very
circuitous way of speaking and there's
so many unnecessary words being said
they sort of fall asleep and you you
lose your train of thought and you're
not paying attention anymore to what
you're saying it's a filibuster strategy
and so you might not notice that what is
that when you cut through all of that
what is actually being said is quite
horrifying and that's certainly the case
here
so cutting through all of the rambling
what she's actually saying is that the
White House is monitoring
Twitter
to make sure that
you know that Twitter is being run in
the way that the White House feels that
it ought to
so much for the rights of private
businesses like we just talked about a
second ago
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
looking for a meaningful gift for your
loved one this year you've got to check
out Legacy box Legacy box is a simple
and safe way to digitize your treasured
videotapes film reels and photos they've
helped over a million families mine
included do just that just send in your
tapes or photos and they'll send them
back in digital format that will always
be protected from floods mold or other
hazards these Irreplaceable moments can
be easily viewed shared and passed on
for future Generations Legacy box is
what Better Homes and Gardens calls the
most sentimental gift for making this
holiday season special last year I you
know infamously refused to fix my
mother's VCR of the Thanksgiving holiday
and to make up for this slate against my
dear sweet mother sweet Grandma Walsh if
you will I got her Legacy box so that
she doesn't have to keep her old VCR
around and more importantly I don't have
to fix it Legacy boxes giving my
listeners their best deal of the Year
this cyber week visit legacybox.com
Walsh to save 65 off your order with
limited quantities available and ready
to ship this deal will go fast so go to
legacybox.com Walsh for 65 off the today
that's legacybox.com Walsh
Julie says Matt over the weekend I
started a petition to try and get you on
The View I got almost 200 signatures
when it suddenly just disappeared
completely gone no email no notification
that I violated any user agreement name
dropping you apparently causes a total
hard reset strangely enough I keep
getting emails reminding me to share my
petition however it's been wiped from
existence I'm so sad that my dream of
watching you School those clucking hens
will never come to be that is
that is pretty interesting which and I
appreciate your efforts because as you
know this is uh one of my greatest
dreams is to appear on The View I know
that Ben Shapiro also talks about how
this is one of his dreams in life
um
I it will probably never be either one
of us I don't think either either one of
us are getting on The View but it
certainly could never be both so it's
got to be one there is a like a
competition here about if any of us if
any if anyone's going to get on The View
I don't see how multiple daily wire
people will get on uh especially after
because if one of us gets on The View
after that happens
um no one else from this company is
going to be allowed on it ever again so
if there's ever a shot it's just gonna
be one shot
and there can be only one right so there
is a competition here
I don't I don't know that a petition is
how these things work
but it's worth trying so what I would
say just make another petition
flood the zone
okay let's let's put a hundred petitions
out there
until they can't ignore us
they can still ignore us but
it's worth trying Jack says as soon as I
heard about ancient apocalypse I knew it
would be the kind of thing that Matt is
into I don't know if you meant that as a
compliment or not Jack but that's how I
choose to take it because absolutely the
minute I heard about the show ancient
apocalypse I knew it would be the kind
of show that I'm into as well and uh and
I watched and I was I was not
disappointed I just as I said yesterday
I really
I don't have to agree with the
conclusions and when it comes to Graham
Hancock I I do think that there are
plenty of uh like we talked about
yesterday there are plenty of
facts that he brings up that are that
are facts and that he brings up a lot of
points that are totally valid my issue
is just with when you get to the final
conclusion like what this is all leading
to and he has this story about the
ancient uh Advanced civilization the
apocalypse and someone from some group
survived it and then they go throughout
the world
uh you know making contact with these
primitive societies and teaching them
the ways of civilization it's like it's
that part that I'm not on board with
because I just think that there's no
direct evidence of that at all
but there is a lot of evidence that the
story we're being told by as he says
mainstream archeology is not
true and the very least is not complete
and I think that's interesting and I and
I also I I just have a uh I have a soft
spot for outside the box thinkers people
come up with really fascinating theories
is why I'm also a big Ancient Aliens guy
too probably won't surprise you to learn
I don't believe almost any of the stuff
in that show I don't I don't even think
it's meant to be believed it's basically
science fiction but I still enjoy it
it's fun to think about and
um
and the thing is even if someone has a
totally outlandish theory that in the
end is not true at all there's value in
listening to it and they might still
bring up points
that you weren't aware of or hadn't
thought about they might cause you to
think about something a little bit
differently even if it's not to agree
with them you're now thinking a little
bit differently about this and you might
see angles that you missed before
so it's sort of like a brainstorming
session right when you when you've ever
if you've ever been in a creative
brainstorming session you need people in
the room who have totally out their
ideas
and their ideas will never be executed
as they're proposed anyway but you need
them there because they're they're the
ones who get you know get your mind
turning they get the wheels turning
all right
Kevin Ross says Matt what you've
predicted is already coming to pass I've
been arguing with idiots on Reddit
wherever Dragon Story Hour is vigorously
defended as I can't help myself I've
made the point repeatedly that I
wouldn't want a stripper or burlesque
dancer reading to kids either the
response is usually there's nothing
sexual about drag queens or even more
concerning are those who say that they'd
actually be fine with a stripper or
burlesque dancer reading to kids yeah I
think that's exactly where this is
heading more and more and more we're
seeing it
um
where where they'll
you know you you might point out that
well you're okay with drag queens and
the sexual environment reading to kids
but if it was any other you know if it
was a woman dressed like that you
wouldn't be okay with it if it was a
female burlesque dancer you wouldn't be
okay with it well I think more and more
of the left is saying yeah actually
we're okay with that too
uh and Rose says kudos to Matt for
saying we need more people like this
rather than fewer instead of less people
like this
this proves Matt is a well-educated man
this is this is one of my many pet
grammatical pet peeves is when people
get less than and fewer than wrong
or when they when they mix up further
and farther
and uh but I noticed myself in a show a
few days ago that I I myself committed
both of those sins so I've
I've realized that I need to
recommit myself and finally time my shoe
says Matt's Native American name would
be Dakota Tusk Chieftain of the walrus
Clan
I like that and since I am as we talked
about yesterday I am a Native American
so I will uh I will accept that name if
the price of your Thanksgiving meal is
left a bad taste in your mouth remember
it's completely normal to keep paying
more and more for the same things right
well no wrong today is the last day of
the daily wire cyber sale and everything
in our shop is 40 off that's right 40
off my John to the walrus book and
plushie bundle 40 off the leftist tears
dog bowl the iconic daily wire truth
bomb so so much else everything else in
fact it's 40 off and don't forget it's
free shipping on orders over 75 and a
free leftist tears tumbler and orders
over a hundred dollars so unless you're
one of the super fans who actually wants
to give us extra money don't wait until
tomorrow go to dailywire.com shop today
for your last chance to get 40 off our
best deal of the year on all gifts worth
giving so go there now now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
you may recall several months ago when
the White House announced one of its
newest hires determined to make his
administration resemble as closely as
possible in early 20th century freak
Show Biden decided to give a top level
job in the department of energy to A Man
Named Sam Britton Britain was named the
deputy assistant Secretary of the office
of spent Fuel and waste disposition and
was granted therefore one of the highest
security clearances in the department
this was interesting though not at all
surprising choice because Britain is a
bizarre cross-dressing creep who
identifies as a non-binary they them and
that's about the most normal thing about
him
so for your reference um here's a video
from just a couple of years ago when
Britain was an activist with the far
left group group The Trevor product
project and here he is explaining in
this video I believe it is the the
importance of pronouns
pronouns are
a
fascinating part of modern culture I
don't think many people think about them
very often until someone like myself or
others say their pronouns
so when I introduce myself I generally
say hi my name's Sam Britton I use they
in them as my pronouns and I serve as
head of advocacy and government Affairs
for the Trevor Project
I give this before I even give my job
because it's the important way that
you're going to describe me not what I
do but who I am
and that I respect for my gender is
really really important
of course you know everything you said
there is nonsense but
um he's dressed even more nonsensically
he looks like he got into a fight with a
Hot Topic mannequin and lost or maybe he
looks like a Jason Bourne cross-dressing
with a costume he bought on clearance at
Party City the day after Halloween worse
yet Britain is also a beastiality
fetishist who enjoys having sex with men
dressed like dogs and if you're
interested you can learn more about that
in one of the Kink 101 workshops that he
taught on college campuses and finally
to complete Britain's resume he also
wrote an article for the advocate in
2015 where he defended a website called
rent boy rent boy was it called which
had been shut down by the feds for
facilitating underage prostitution and
in the since deleted article Britain
worried that there would be serious
ramifications quote unquote to the gay
community if the prostitution site was
taken down he argued that rent boy was
performing a service by giving young
people a way to quote earn a living by
selling their bodies
so this guy is to summarize a sick
twisted deviant and for that reason not
in spite of it but because of it he was
made a high level official in the bite
Administration and that brings us to the
latest news first reported by a site
called alphanews.com and here it is
quote law enforcement at the
Minneapolis-St Paul International
Airport were alerted to a missing
suitcase in the baggage claim area on
September 16th the adult female victim
said she flew into MSP on a Delta flight
from New Orleans and went to retrieve
her check bag at Carousel 7. airport
records confirmed the navy blue Vera
Bradley roller bag arrived at 4 40 PM
but was missing from the carousel so law
enforcement reviewed video surveillance
footage from the baggage claim area
and observed Britain removing a navy
blue roller bag from Carousel 7
according to a criminal complaint the
complaint says Britain removed a luggage
tag from the bag placed into a handbag
that he was carrying and then left the
area at a quick Pace Britain arrived at
MSP airport around 2 4 27 on American
Airlines flight from Washington DC but
did not check a bag police showed the
surveillance video to the victim and she
confirmed it was her bag
now by the way just a side note here
take special note of the fact that he
didn't check a bag himself
which would negate any defense that he
took the bag by accident thinking that
you know was one of his own bags
there's no reason for him to even be in
the baggage claim area if he didn't
check a bag to begin with
unless he was there specifically to
steal a bag which appears to be the case
back to the article says Britain left
the airport in an Uber for a stay at the
Intercontinental Saint Paul Riverfront
Hotel where he checked in with the blue
bag the complaint says he returned to
MSP on September 18th with the bag in
hand for departing flight back to
Washington DC uh surveillance video from
Dulles International Airport shows
Britain traveling with the bag on
October 9th return trip from Europe the
victim said the estimated value of the
bag and its contents was around 2 325
dollars police questioned Britain about
the missing bag in an October 19th phone
call uh ninth phone call and asked him
directly if he took anything that did
not belong to him uh not that I know of
Britain allegedly responded he later
admitted to taking the bag but said the
clothes inside were his
I don't know how that would work
according to the complaint if I had
taken the wrong bag I'm happy to return
it but I don't have any clothes for
another individual uh that was my
clothes when I opened the bag he told
police
so someone else flying from a different
city had a bag that it magically had his
clothes in it Britain allegedly called
the investigating office two hours later
and apologized for not being completely
honest this time Britain said that he
took the bag because he was tired and
thought that it was his the complaint
says
he was tired sure that makes sense I
mean who hasn't been so tired while
traveling that they wander down to the
baggage claim bleary-eyed take a random
bag walk out with it take an Uber to the
hotel and then keep the bag and travel
with it again two weeks later
happens to the best of us
if it's possible his excuse only gets
worse from here because he later told
police that when he opened the bag in
his hotel room that he you know at that
point he noticed that it wasn't his but
he was nervous that they'd think that he
stole the bag so his solution was to
take all the clothes out and leave them
in the drawers in the hotel room but
take the bag with him
because he said it you thought it would
be weird to leave the bag with its
contents in the room
I suppose it's no surprise that this guy
doesn't have the clearest concept of
what is weird and what isn't
because if he did he'd realize that of
all the choices he could have made
throughout this ordeal he made each time
definitely the weirdest one
and that's if his story is even true
which of course it almost certainly
isn't uh police say that they never
recovered any clothes from his hotel
room uh by all appearances then he kept
not only the bag but he kept the
clothing as well and so he's now charged
with uh with a felony
Okay so
this whole Saga raises a question
it raises indeed more than one question
um and so a few of those questions are
things like you know why would this guy
brazenly steal a random woman's luggage
I mean didn't he realize there are
security cameras all over the airport
it's an airport
and it may have been a nice suitcase as
far as suitcases go I don't know but was
it worth the criminal charge and public
embarrassment that we're sure to follow
you could not choose a worse place for
stealing luggage than an airport I don't
recommend stealing luggage at all but if
you're going to try it you're better off
trying to steal it from like the store
where it's sold than from an airport
where there are 15 cameras every Five
Paces
so what could possibly motivate this
sort of behavior
as to that last question I can only
speculate
but there is one answer that seems
pretty evident here it would seem that
Britain took the bag
because he has a cross-dressing fetish
and he gets off on the idea of wearing
some strange woman's clothing
why is he willing to put his career
reputation on the line well partly
because he knows he's in a protected
class and he can do whatever he wants
but also partly because deviant perverts
like Sam Britton are willing to risk
pretty much anything in pursuit of their
weird sick pleasures
they are driven almost exclusively by
their sexual desires this is true of any
fetishist who feels the need to live out
those fetishes in public
not only to live them out publicly but
to force the public to actively
participate in them
because this is what modern tolerance is
so often about it's about allowing
people usually men to involve the whole
world in their sexual fetishes
many of The Men Who call themselves
trans are really just Auto gynophiles
and many of them who call themselves
non-binary are really just
cross-dressing fetishes it's as simple
as that
and we have elevated The Fetish to a
lifestyle that we all not only have to
tolerate
which we shouldn't even have to do that
but but also uh uh uh
affirm it
which is to participate in it we have
empowered these troubled people in our
society rather than encouraging them to
seek psychological treatment and
spiritual healing for their perverse and
unnatural desires which is what they
need
and when you Empower that enough you end
up and you Empower it to the level that
Sam Britton has been literally empowered
by being given a position in the White
House you end up with exactly what
happened at the Minneapolis Airport and
that is why Sam Britton is most
certainly and I imagine probably not for
the first time in this show canceled and
I'll do it for this portion of the show
as you move over to members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]